about TPP you wrote pretty powerfully
about that just recently about TPP and
how important that is tell us why that
is so critical you've raised it if we
don't do TPP you'll find all of these
Asian countries signing trade deals with
China and we're going to be left out of
that market it is half the people in the
world live in Asia you cannot not do
business there and if we have our hands
tied and lack of contacts or a lack of
treaties it just does not bode well for
America it's easy to stand up there and
blame global trade for everything the
truth of the matter is we have to trade
we live in a world where you cannot stop
this and if we're going to create jobs
for Americans over here we have to sell
our products over there if we're going
to have good bargains for our cuts
consumers here we have to be able to
trade and buy things from overseas it is
a two-way street the fly in the ointment
is technology which is going to give the
spoils to those with a better education
so we've got to go back to mystically
and work on our education system and the
more business we do we'll try we can
make up for the technological disruption
in a job market there's two reasons we
have to do TPP first is economic as the
mayor said our ability to sell goods
around the world is really critical so
this is TPP gives us market access and
the second is strategic it's important
America leads we have to basically set
the rules of global trade global traits
going to go on whether we're
participating or not it's up to the
United States to lead and we've done
that we've gone and made a deal with 11
countries fastest-growing economies in
the world and fastest growing market
place in the world now we have take
advantage of it so the question is I
is it dead it's not dead can it be past
it in the lame-duck I think it's
absolutely possible to get done and
we're working the president has been
absolutely a leader on this he's been
working with Congress all of us have
been working with various members in the
Senate in the house about the importance
we've been helping to demonstrate within
their districts the jobs that depend
upon our ability to sell around the
world so no it's not dead